hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery Titans review you may
have seen some of the footage they've
been dropping lately because of New York
Comic Con the series is gonna be
released this Friday so whereas like the
flash is a Tuesday show Titans is
basically a Friday show for all 12
episodes so I'll explain the schedule at
the end of this - but if you're just
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I do
weekly giveaways this time it's for the
DC streaming service all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so most
important questions how does Titans feel
differently from the other DC TV series
like the flash and arrow how is the
story how are the actors how is the
fight choreography the costumes and what
is the future of the show feel like
based on stuff they've already confirmed
that they're gonna be doing coming up in
the characters that they have access to
that maybe the other shows do not like
whatever you think of it now is it going
to become a bigger show in future
seasons it with a story expand or will
it be more like arrow where you sort of
have to mind C and d-list characters
because you can't use those big Batman
level characters it's written to be more
like a cable show in terms of graphic
violence and dark tones and themes
imagine if arrow weren't on a major
Network and work program for young
children like there are a lot of rules
that govern how much blood or nudity
that they can show on the CW network
there are no such rules for any
streaming network they can show whatever
they want they can be as graphic or
hardcore as they want so they don't pull
any of those punches the first trailer
where it seems like Robin kills all
those people is actually misleading he
doesn't actually kill anyone in the way
they edited that F Batman drop was a
little bit misleading too because he
says it in a different way in the actual
episode so just call it bad editing or a
bad trailer or whatever the later
trailers I think have been a much better
picture of what the show actually feels
like and they polished a lot of the
special effects and we have footage from
further out in the season so you get to
actually see them using their powers
together if you've even brushed past a
comic book in your life you probably
sense that the arc that they're building
towards because the story is built
around Raven and Robin is the terror of
Trigon for their first big arc I haven't
seen the finale so I don't know
we're gonna be seeing him later this
season or if they're gonna save that for
season 2 because a normal Network show
would do it's Star Wars style where you
learn about Darth Vader and he's this
big villain of your first big arc then
you learn about the big boss behind him
the emperor in your second big arc your
Empire Strikes Back so it just remains
to be seen how quickly they'll blow
through that terror of Trigon story
because that's all about Trigon coming
into our plane of existence because
really the first season is all about the
Titans coming together learning about
their powers and then obviously getting
their [ __ ] together by the end of the
season I'll talk about plans for future
seasons because Jeff Jones did tease
specific comic book arts but that
started putting the cart before the
horse one of the good things I think the
series does especially in the pilot
episode is tease other big characters it
does a lot of world-building so you get
a sense for who else exists in the
universe relative to the Holy Trinity
Batman Superman and Wonder Woman
for example Donna Troy is the character
during season 1 a supporting character
more of a main character during season 2
the clips that they've been dropping
give you an idea for some of the
character interactions generally each of
the characters bring a different tone to
the group so like Beast Boy is meant to
be a little more lighthearted Raven is a
total goth girl Starfire is meant to be
this grand free spirit and Robin is just
burdened with a lot of Darkness that he
carries with him from his time with
Batman that he's trying to deal with
trying to find a better way to be a
superhero
that's not quite so hardcore all of you
were asking about the Batman of it I
felt like they did a really good job of
using him I don't want to give too much
away about how the series uses him but
Batman is a very important part of the
series you've probably seen that clip
with Jason Todd where they reference him
it's really surreal that they have so
much Batman stuff in scenes going on
during titans wall they're also closing
down the Gotham TV show over on box one
of the things I really like about it is
that they go to that comic book place
with all the characters really fast they
don't kiss too much Christopher Nolan
but trying to make it really real-world
like oh they wouldn't be wearing their
comic book costumes here like they
wouldn't be wearing these bright colors
they did make it as a comic book show
like the flash is a comic book show most
of the time he's running around in his
Flash uniform they're doing comic book
arcs that is what I look for in a comic
book series even if we want to change a
couple rosters or make a cup
- I'm still looking for those comic book
stories and that is one of the big
promises of titans is that they're only
doing 12 to 13 episodes per season
meaning that it's much easier to tell
those big comic book arts that you love
Deathstroke for instance he was a big
question mark when they first announced
the series are we gonna see that because
he's such a huge character for the Teen
Titans recently a New York Comic Con
Jeff John said we would be stupid if we
did not do Deathstroke or the Judas
contract run he applied it would be be
on season 2 and it would be a different
version of Deathstroke it would not be
the Manu Bennett or the Joe Manganiello
version and beyond that they have Donna
Troy so obviously big Donna Troy Ark
they have Jason Todd under the Red Hood
is something to look forward to
obviously that's a big enough idea that
you could do a Red Hood in the outlaws
spin-off TV show but obviously putting
the cart before the horse first you have
to kill off Jason Todd then you can do
that arc so I'm not expecting that to
happen for a couple years at least but
in terms of the character interactions I
would say all the actors are actually
really good that they chose Raven takes
a little bit of getting used to I feel
like she's one of those young actors
like Willa Holland that gets better in
leaps and bounds
each episode you could just tell they
get a lot of experience so I feel like
any of the weaknesses that they found
when they were filming the pilot they
were able to correct later in the season
so whatever the trailer footage has made
it seem like the characters are capable
of what their powers are compared to the
comic book versions they will eventually
get to full comic book level by the end
of the season so I feel like that was
one of the misleading things about the
early trailers because people just
assumed that it was always going to look
like this so thankfully that is not the
case
you know big fan of Robins costume
probably one of the better costumes that
I've seen from the DC TV shows because
it's the Berlanti group that's helping
produce this show the same person that
makes all the superhero costumes for the
other DC TV shows made all the costumes
for Titans I don't really consider it a
spoiler to say that all the costumes
evolved by the end of the season yeah
early on I'm not a big fan of Starfire's
costume they're trying to honor the Marv
Wolfman George Perez New Teen Titans
origin so that's why Starfire looks like
she's from that era but it doesn't
really work because the rest of the
series is made to feel very contemporary
so you have this person that's stepped
right out of the 70s walking around
with Dick Grayson and all these other
people for a couple episodes so
thankfully they fixed that by the end of
the season the special effects look
really good they've done a better job of
showing that off in the more recent
trailers like you see star fires fire
ability like she roasting people alive
beast boy's transformations there was a
big question about what that was gonna
look like
early on eventually yeah he does look
green like he does in the comics even
though the early pictures made it seem
like that was not the case a lot of you
were asking about cyborgs and other core
Teen Titans members like I've already
said Donna Troy Wonder Girl will be a
member to the team in the future cyborg
is a character in the universe he's
going to be introduced on the Doom
Patrol spin-off TV show you meet some of
those characters during Titans future
season but Doom Patrol won't premiere
till next year this is actually the full
schedule of release for all the DC
Universe shows in the next year so you
can see that Young Justice is gonna be
the next thing that's up as we expected
they're breaking that season in half we
can talk more about this when we get
trailer videos for some of these other
things like you just saw the Harley
Quinn TV show they'll probably be a Doom
Patrol trailer before the end of the
year we probably won't see swampthing
footage till sometime early next year
because they haven't started shooting
that TV show yet but just in general
prognosis is actually very positive for
the future of what Titans can be as a
show they have access to all those
Batman characters like I said Batman is
a character on the TV show already so
they start off feeling like a much
bigger show and a much bigger world in
terms of which superheroes exist
Superman Batman and Wonder Woman
than any of the other DC TV shows
there's all kinds of name drops and
references Easter eggs in each episode
flash is back tomorrow so I'll do my
flash episode 1 video like I would
normally do Tuesday night so everybody
get really hype let me know what you
think about Titans which you have a
chance to watch the first couple of
episodes I'll do an Easter Egg video
when the first episode does drop but
just leave all your requests in the
comments below click here for that new
Tom Holland Avengers 4 video and click
here to rewatch that titans netflix
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight